wir kaufen und sammeln unser ganzes
leben lang dinge die ihr eigentlich gar
nicht brauchen am ende landet vieles
davon einfach auf single am anfang in
den job anfängt ist es erschreckend aber
mit der zeit siehst du dass sein vater
lauf der dinge ist ich habe mich nie
darum gekümmert wer eigentlich hinter
uns aufräumt und was mit den sachen
passiert wenn wir sterben flüssigkeiten
und an flecken auf dem boden sind ist
das auch ein bisschen
verstorben der wohnung und das hat man
brauchen kann das treppenhaus beim
parken kam es dann wieder vor dass man
ein bisschen enttäuscht ist weil einfach
die flüssigkeit am boden lag war jetzt
arbeite ich eine woche als in früheren
bei familie spielt
das sind meine neuen kollegen
haushaltsauflösung und trödel könig
jürgen stüber kaufen zeit helfen das ist
mein ganzes leben chefin und ehefrau
irina lernen kannst du auch aber das
muss im blut
lkw-fahrer und firmen urgestein
christian kemming entrümpler florin pack
experte jonas und das bin ich
eigentlich arbeite ich als reporterin
bei bild